[Musique]
bienvenue à bagdad pour ce nouveau
numéro de reporter sur france 24 nous
inaugurerons ici dans la capitale
irakienne une nouvelle série sur les
frontières du monde véritable point
chaud de la géopolitique nous irons la
semaine prochaine à la frontière entre
le brésil et la guyane française zone de
tous les trafics nous irons sur la
frontière entre la chine et le laos et
sur la frontière entre l'ouganda et le
kenya mais aujourd'hui direction le sud
ouest de l'irak vers la frontière avec
l'arabie saoudite véritables zones
stratégiques dans le désert d'arabie
cette frontière est fermée depuis la
première guerre du golfe mais depuis
2020 rouvrent progressivement au trafic
commercial signe d'un réchauffement
diplomatique entre ces deux puissances
régionales l'irak et l'arabie saoudite
c'est un reportage de lucile wasserman
pour france 2
[Musique]
c'est bon ce n'est pas périmé
au coeur du désert entre l'irak et
l'arabie saoudite
des camions patientaient en files
indiennes des hommes s'affairent autour
des cargaisons surveillé de près par les
forces de l'ordre outre mois un produit
pour vérifier les dates de péremption ou
vos hasard
à harar le poste frontière reprend vie
aujourd'hui 29 camions sont actuellement
à cours des changes et 8 sont prêts à
sortir ok beaucoup sont là depuis
plusieurs jours oui il y en a qui sont
là depuis deux trois jours déjà après
l'invasion du koweït par saddam hussein
en 1990 l'arabie saoudite avait fermé sa
frontière et couper toute relation avec
l'irak ce n'est que trente ans plus tard
le 18 novembre 2020 que le poste d'art
arts s'est à nouveau entre ouvert
plus important c'est que ce ne soit pas
périmé hockey 18 décharger
des charges des charges
c'est actuellement le seul point de
passage sur les 800 kilomètres de
frontière entre les deux pays une
soixantaine de camions s'y rend tous les
jours et le général ahmad touma
responsable irakien du poste-frontière
imagine déjà un avenir radieux comme
beaucoup de camions transportent des
matériaux de construction de l'arabie
saoudite vers l'irak mais les
marchandises sont de plus en plus variés
l'ouverture de ce poste est encore
récente mais elle va offrir beaucoup
d'opportunités d'emploi aux irakiens de
la région d'al-anbar et de rothbach
[Musique]
et ce en liquide de refroidissement les
pneus on est prêt pour demain
mohammed jassem fait partie de ces
irakiens dont la vie a changé depuis le
18 novembre 2020 avant ce chauffeur
routier de la région d'al-anbar n'avait
que peu d'options pour ces marchandises
impossible d'aller en syrie trop
dangereuse seule la jordanie lui offrait
encore quelques débouchés comment
l'ouverture du poste frontière d'art art
c'est l'ouverture d'une nouvelle fois
pour mieux gagner ma vie un voyage
pérard ça me prend cinq ou six jours
alors pour la jordanie ça peut me
prendre un mois au total à cause des
régulations en fait ça n'a pas seulement
augmenter mes revenus ça m'a aussi rendu
à ma vie de famille
mohamed peut désormais enchaîner les
trajets tout en profitant de ses enfants
comment tu vas petit round toi aussi tu
voudras conduire plus tard mais pourquoi
il est au youth f il dort
[Musique]
il prépare aujourd'hui son 45e voyage en
inde en verre art il connaît bien la
route et mesure tout l'intérêt de cette
destination pour les chauffeurs routiers
alors mohamed en fait bénéficier son
entourage
on va partir à quatre camions mais trois
neveux et moi pour transporter des
bouteilles de jus et d'eau à la
frontière
un peu plus de 600 km de là en arabie
saoudite
mme hussein el hendy profite lui aussi
d'une soirée en famille mais tous ses
proches ne pourront pas être là ce
saoudien qui évite à harar appartient à
une tribu qui s'étend sur plusieurs pays
de la région une partie de sa famille et
de ses amis vite en irak
bonjour mon ami comment tu vas
ça va ça va d'étouars
regarde je suis dans un supermarché et
il ya de plus en plus de produits
saoudien a c'est super
bon si les ouvre pour les visites
j'espère que tu viendras rapidement
bientôt bientôt pour l'heure le poste
frontière d'art art n'est ouvert qu'aux
commerces les civils n'ont toujours pas
l'autorisation de traverser alors les
fêtes de la tribu de moussaïd ne
regroupe que ses membres saoudiens en
attendant le jour où les irakiens
pourront enfin se joindre à eux
l'attenté
vous savez quand la frontière était
encore ouverte aux civils on se sentait
très proches les uns des autres c'était
très facile d'y aller les traditions la
nourriture était très similaire on avait
même l'impression d'être dans le même
pays au final ce n'est qu'à une heure de
route après tout pendant 30 ans tous ces
échanges ont été interrompues avec la
fermeture de la frontière en 1990 c'est
tout un mode de vie qui a disparu
ma dernière visite en irak
c'était en 1989 je suis allé voir de la
famille des amis là bas j'ai fait un peu
de tourisme je suis resté dix jours et
j'ai bougé dans pas mal de régions à
l'époque notre relation avec l'irak
était encore très bonne après il ya eu
la guerre du golfe et tout s'est dégradé
ils ont fermé la frontière ils nous ont
interdit de passer je n'y suis pas
retourné depuis
l'ouverture commerciale du poste
frontière darar redonne espoir aux
communautés transfrontalière peut-être
un jour proche moussaïd pourra-t-il
reprendre ces voyages comme le font
aujourd'hui
mohammed et ses neveux côté irakien
il est 5h30 du matin et ils vont devoir
parcourir près de 600 km pour atteindre
le poste frontière d'art art
la route traverse toute la région
d'al-anbar ce qui rassure mohamed
les autres routes ces peuples
il ya beaucoup d'échangés à bassorah sud
est mais on n'a pas de contacts là bas
donc on peut faire face à des
irrégularités disons
cette nouvelle route n'échappe pas à la
corruption qui gangrène l'irak mais ici
mohamed se sont moins vulnérables
il connaît les autorités locales alors
il espère que l'ouverture de la
frontière permettra à sa région de se
développer
on serait heureux que nos voisins
saoudiens vienne et investissent en irak
tout le désert d'al anbar est totalement
abandonnée il ya de quoi faire
honnêtement s'ils investissent ici il
pourrait fournir beaucoup d'emplois aux
habitants de cette région
avec le réchauffement des relations
entre l'arabie saoudite et l'irak les
projets transfrontaliers se sont
multipliées modernisation de la route
mise en culture d'un million d'hectares
dans cette zone désertique mais pour
l'heure rien ne s'est concrétisé et les
bords de routes restent désespérément
désert
constate comme ça parce que c'est
toujours complètement vide ici jusqu'à
la frontière il n'y a pas de restaurants
pas de supermarché même pas aux postes
frontières vous verrez
les investissements arrivent au compte
gouttes l'instabilité politique et
sécuritaire de l'irak inquiète toujours
les saoudiens et l' influence de l'iran
écrasante en irak leur laisse peu de
marge de manoeuvre
pourtant l'ouverture de la frontière
fait déjà sentir ses effets en 2020 les
échanges commerciaux entre irak et
arabie saoudite ont augmenté de 15% et
côté saoudien moussaïd constatent de
nombreux changements
regardez là tout autour il ya beaucoup
de rénovations
ces travailleurs agrandissent la route
et construisent un espace de
stationnement
c'est depuis l'ouverture du poste
frontière beaucoup de jeunes des
villages voisins où aussi acheter des
camions pour faire du commerce avec
l'irak
il faut comprendre que pour nous ça ou
bien le poste frontière d'art art c'est
notre porte d'entrée vers l'europe et
pas seulement vers l'irak quand ça a
fermé le commerce s'est effondré ici
donc l'ouverture est très très
importante pour la région
pour art art et sa région l'une des
moins productifs d'arabie saoudite
l'ouverture de la frontière et la
promesse d'un renouveau économique
vient la serono lama quoi de neuf
alors qu'en moussaïd retrouve ses amis
dans un café de la ville les
conversations oscille entre nostalgie et
foi en l'avenir avant toutes nos maisons
ont été construites avec du ciment
irakien il était réputé et puis on
manger du riz rac1 il est plus épais on
adorait ça ou encore le gamer ce fromage
très épais on utilisait tellement de
produire 1 kg 1
je pense que dans cinq ans cette zone va
redevenir une zone d'attraction ça va
faire revenir les commerçants et les
grandes entreprises ti louvre
complètement le poste frontière la
demande pour louer des terres ici
devraient augmenter et la région va se
développer
en attendant ces jours meilleurs
l'augmentation du fret routier reste
l'effet le plus visible de la
réouverture de la frontière
on y arrive c'est l'entrée là bas on
doit faire un premier arrêt ici pour
s'enregistrer
après dix heures de route mohamed arrive
enfin au poste d'art art
oui oui je reviens
il ya une nouvelle taxe à payer
apparemment d'une dizaine d'euros
mais ils ne veulent pas que je paye
devant la caméra
voilà le poste frontière tout a été
refait par le gouvernement saoudien ici
il leur a fallu je pense cinq mois pour
terminer les constructions
c'est ici que s'arrêtera son voyage dans
une cour grillagée où sont parqués les
camions en provenance des deux pays les
marchandises ils seront échangés puis
les chauffeurs repartiront chacun de
leur côté à ce jour les hommes n'ont
toujours pas le droit de passer seuls
les cargaisons traverseront la frontière
une restriction qui ne facilite pas la
logistique
bonjour
je voudrais savoir quand les camions
saoudiens vont arriver tu sais
écoute je sais pas on dirait qu'il ya un
problème avec les chauffeurs de l'autre
côté
et puis sont indiens j'arrive pas à
communiquer avec l'autre
ils vont arriver plus tard que prévu
c'est sûr
ok bon nous on est la frontière on
attend on se tient au courant
mohamed devra attendre plusieurs jours
sur ce terrain vague sans aucune
commodités
certains chauffeurs sont là depuis plus
d'une semaine et laissent éclater leur
colère
il n'y a rien dans cette cour ils n'ont
pas été foutus d'organiser ça proprement
franchement regardez c'est déplorable
la zone n'est même pas pavées ses salles
il n'y a même pas de toilettes pour les
chauffeurs
ils nous prennent 200 $ pour accéder à
cet espace mais ils font quoi de cet
argent
même si elle est encore imparfaite et
parfois frustrante l'ouverture du poste
frontière darar marque le début d'une
nouvelle ère dans les relations entre
l'irak et l'arabie saoudite pour les
populations transfrontalières
elle est synonyme de nouveaux espoirs
bagdad et ryad parle aujourd'hui
d'ouvrir deux points de passages
supplémentaires
et voilà pour ce premier épisode
consacré aux frontières du monde tourné
ici en irak par lucile wasserman la
semaine prochaine nous irons sur le
fleuve oyapock en amazonie découvrir les
700 kilomètres d'une frontière très
difficilement contrôlable
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci de
l'avoir suivi et on se retrouve très
bientôt sur scène